Fabiana wrote in I don't believe that
Republican policy is good for African
Americans but can you talk about what
Republicans could do to better appeal to
black voters without just becoming
progressive right so yeah I mean it's
very easy to say if Republicans just
adopted progressive policies then they
would better appeal to black voters
because oftentimes those policies are
better for non-white voters I actually
think that there's a major opportunity
to appeal to black voters and again I'm
talking not that I am giving Republicans
advice but there is a significant
contingent the African American
population is quite religious there is a
very religious component to the African
American population in the United States
and I believe that you already see that
in some clays cases where some of the
sort of more prominent black Republicans
are often religious leaders or
religiously connected individuals
pastors from conservative churches or
whatever the religious african-american
community might serve as one of the
better entry ways for Republicans and
again I hope that they fail I hope that
they don't succeed in this type of
pandering to black voters because on
policy it's really not Republicans who
have the interests of not non-white
voters in mind but I think that the
religion component could be there and
when you think back to proposition 8 in
California this was the sort of
referendum on gay marriage by cabaña to
ban gay marriage a big part of that
being defeated of gay marriage being
defeated so to speak was religious black
voters in California so if I were
thinking cynically as a Republican right
not in ways where I can actually help
african-american voters but just ways
that I can get their votes I'd probably
be thinking pretty heavily along the
lines of religion in some way shape or
form and remember prop 8 passed on the
same day that Barack Obama was elected
president that's the first time yep
there probably was some overlap there
between the black population that wanted
to ban gay marriage and wanted to vote
for the first black president yep I
wouldn't be surprised
there are also sort of
conservative arguments that you can make
that would potentially appeal to black
voters like for example we know that for
the same drug crimes that are sort of
engaged in at similar rates by whites
and blacks blacks are more likely to be
indicted prosecuted convicted and
sentenced to more time right and on the
Left we tend to take an approach of it's
discriminatory it's more of a social
justice approach it we should be dealing
with drugs as an issue of Public Health
not as an issue of criminality etc the
right could maybe try to appeal to black
and Latino voters on that issue by
saying listen we the prisons are a waste
of money
and black folks and Hispanic folks are
disproportionately impacted by the
prison industrial complex and we want to
change that and it'll be better for you
and it'll be better for the economy
because we're gonna spend less money on
prisons or something like that like
there's probably ways it's and it's
interesting because they've chosen not
really to do that right there's really
been no outreach in any serious manner
that's credible to the non-white
population of the United States by
Republicans they pick off some votes
here and there I think there are
arguments to be made I think that they
are totally pandering arguments but
there are arguments to be made and we
don't really hear them very often
there's a lot here it's very nuanced but
you're saying that it's not enough for
say the president United States Donald
Trump a Republican to nominate ben
Carson now as his Secretary of Housing
and Urban Development that did not have
Omarosa on it as a having Omarosa on as
an advisor if anything is working
against him and it's also not enough for
the President of the United States
States to say where's my
african-american while looking out into
a crowd while wearing a make America
great again hat that was not a move that
really bolstered the black vote for
Donald Trump shockingly maybe to some
but not to others we've got a great
bonus show for you today david
pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com slash david pakman show are
the two ways that you can get access to
bonus show where we will continue the
party here on this Friday